déposer un recours 15 voix c'est parler
deux hommes dans ce scrutin très serré
André van Holbecq se plaignait d'avoir
été accusé de censure dans des tracts
qui l'estimaient mensonger la justice
lui donne donc raison Pierre-François
Viard dispose lui d'un mois pour faire
appel
justice toujours et le verdict dans la
faire Mickaël Kiri l'homme s'était
opposé au contrôle d'identité de sa
femme portant le voile intégrale il
écope de trois mois de prison avec
sursis assorti de 1000 euros d'amende
Anthony rechetter cet après-midi à la
cour d'appel de Versailles avec Patrick
Jacques de Dixmude
sa peine a finalement été confirmée
comment première instance Michael Kery a
été condamné à trois mois de prison avec
sursis par la cour d'appel de Versailles
le jeune homme converti à l'islam à ses
ans c'était violemment interposée au
contrôle d'identité de sa femme
Cassandra Belin portant le ni caban
juillet 2013 à Trappes
conformons réquisition du parquet cette
condamnation est assortie d'une amende
de 1000 euros auquel s'ajoutent
désormais 150 euros que devra verser
Michael Kerry aux trois policiers ayant
effectué ce contrôle d'identité cette
décision intervient quelques heures
après un arrêt de la Cour européenne des
droits de l'homme de Strasbourg jugeant
légitime l'interdiction de voile
intégrale en France validant ainsi la
loi du 11 octobre 2010 l'épouse de
Michael kieri Cassandra Belin condamné
elle à un mois de prison avec sursis
pour avoir insulté ses policiers pendant
le contrôle sera rejugé le 22 octobre
pour rappel en juillet 2013 se contrôle
avait entraîné de violents affron
tements entre force de l'ordre et jeune
dans la ville
la France en quart de finale face à
l'Allemagne si vous étiez avec nous hier
en direct vous avez vécu une bonne
partie de l'ambiance sur 50 ans en
Yvelines retour sur cette très belle
soirée avec Olivier Maniscalco et
Jonathan villemane
une ambiance stressante une tension
palpable hier soir dans ce peuple de
voisin le Bretonneux les supporters des
Bleus s'inquiètent au fur et à mesure
que les minutes ses graines dans ce 8e
de finale de Coupe du monde face au
Nigéria l'équipe de France ne rassure
pas
vraiment un match à élimination directe
les premiers match on savait qu'on avait
le droit à une erreur donc à envoyer les
personnes qui discutaient qui étaient un
peu plus souriante joyeuse etc donc non
non là c'est vraiment
c'est vraiment bizarre on voit bien que
ça il y a une élimination à la fin du
match donc ça peut se terminer là-dessus
mais ça terminera pas là et on est fait
les Bleus ne vont pas s'arrêter là après
34 nouvelles minutes étouffantes en
seconde période le milieu de terrain
français Paul Pogba libère l'équipe de
France d'un joli coup de tête les
supporters peuvent respirer
enfin de match les Bleus signent même un
deuxième but la France est qualifiée
pour les quarts de finale de la Coupe du
Monde et affrontera l'Allemagne vendredi
les supporters eux exultent et voient
déjà l'équipe de France aller plus loin
c'est génial c'est excellent j'y croyez
pas au début mais là rien du mal on a eu
du mal on a eu beaucoup on va y aller
prochain match des Bleus donc face à
l'Allemagne ce vendredi 18h l'Allemagne
qui a écarté l'Algérie hier soir
également les supporters des Fennec ont
longtemps cru à l'exploit et après le
parcours historique de leur équipe ils
étaient loin d'être accablés aujourd'hui
quelques réactions recueillies par
Anthony chez le Timone
l'Algérie a échoué aux portes d'un quart
de finale de Coupe du Monde battue par
les Allemands ce mardi matin dans le
quartier des Merisiers attrapent
rencontre avec quelques supporters
satisfaits de l'épopée de leur équipe
une qualification au huitième de finale
c'était une première pour les fenêtres
franchement ils ont bien joué avec eux
ils ont fait de 1 franchement un bon
match quoi je suis pas déçu c'est un bon
match que on avait le plaisir de le
regarder et puis il faut toujours en
perdant un gagnant je trouve très bien
le match
content du parcours de l'Algérie et ils
ont bien ils ont bien travaillé ils ont
bien joué et les supporters de l'équipe
d'Algérie tournent maintenant leur
regard vers l'équipe de France qui
jouera son quart de finale vendredi soir
justement contre l'Allemagne
de France je vis en France et j'ai
toujours eu en France moi je vois 2 1 2
0 pour la France on va voir le match de
hier vendredi prochain là il y a la
France avec l'Allemagne on va voir faire
la revanche comment ça se passe aussi
mais je sais très bien que l'Allemagne
ils vont ils vont faire il y a 4 à 0 à
la France et j'ai oublié les amours pour
la France mais oui ici voilà merci
Monsieur et que bon bah
ils vont bien se défendre l'équipe
française ils ont une bonne équipe quand
même rendez-vous vendredi à partir de
18h pour suivre l'équipe de France et
peut-être voir des drapeaux tricolores
sur les façades des immeubles
on quitte ce Mondial de foot invité de
ce journal à présent Valérie Traumat
bonsoir vous êtes c'est la nouvelle
responsable de la FCPE des Yvelines la
Fédération des conseils de parents
d'élèves des écoles publiques vous êtes
vous-même d'ailleurs merde donc de
famille mais aussi enseignante il me
semble aux exercer aussi cette
profession quel est votre parcours au
sein de la FCPE par contre ça a commencé
au début en fait c'est comme tous
parents c'est le fait de vouloir mieux
comprendre le fonctionnement de l'école
et puis donc j'adore en fait à la
Fédération des conseils de parents
d'élèves et on se rend compte que
finalement l'école c'est c'est un
méandre avec les temps qui se
pose les uns aux autres effectivement
plutôt c'était l'engagement il vient de
là c'est mieux comprendre et puis de
d'aider les parents à mieux comprendre
on comprend pas forcément et c'est les
deux mondes avec celui des enseignants
qui ont parfois du mal à communiquer
vous vouliez simplifier peut-être un
petit peu tout ça c'est un mandat qui va
durer un an c'est vous étiez le pour une
année votre priorité défendre l'école
publique laïque et gratuite alors
expliquez-nous un petit peu ces axes
alors au niveau des
lifco en fait on a une fédération de
conseils de parents on se retrouve en
tant que parents en fait et on porte les
mêmes valeurs ce qui peut être différent
avec des associations en fait sur les
écoles ou effectivement les parents vont
se retrouver mais plus pour des
gestions en fait au niveau d'une école
alors effectivement nous on s'intéresse
au niveau de l'association
réservées en fait à certains élèves
alors que normalement si vous voulez la
réussite de tous ça se passe bien à
l'école publique où on met tous les
enfants en fait ensemble la prochaine
famille peut avoir le choix aussi du
moment que la famille a le choix
je pense que si on veut vraiment
construire une société idéale ou tous
les enfants s'épanouissent en fait
ensemble c'est bien on se rencontrant
tous les uns les autres et effectivement
faire de monde séparés il y a pas
d'intérêt parce que on constate
aujourd'hui justement que les
inscriptions régulièrement rentrées
après rentrer augmentent dans ces écoles
privées ça veut dire quoi que l'école
publique échoue pour l'instant ne répond
pas aux attentes des parents pas
spécialement je pense que c'est lié
aussi à la crise de la société en
général les parents ont mettre en fait
une pression démesurée je pense pour la
réussite scolaire des élèves c'est pas
forcément fait l'axe je pense à choisir
pour que les enfants s'épanouissent et
là effectivement je pense pas que
l'école privée gagne ton terrain que ça
j'ai pas les chiffres je pourrais pas le
vérifier
mais c'est aussi une façon pour
certaines familles qu'on rencontre sur
le terrain de se dire que comme elles
n'arrivent pas éduquer les enfants
finalement des fois elles font aussi le
choix de l'école privée en disant bah si
du coup vu qu'on n'y arrive pas là
peut-être que l'école privée arrivera
côté FCPE on n'est pas du tout sur cette
position de se dire que ça à l'école
éduquer les enfants en fait c'est
complémentaire
à la tête de la FCPE des Yvelines vous
succédez à Pierre frodot forcément une
nouvelle présidente arrive quels sont
les rapports avec l'ancien président
vous vous inscrivez dans la continuité
vous voulez tout révolutionner comment
ça se passe aujourd'hui
on a un travail de sur du long terme
avec des des actions qui ont été
engagées en fait sur les précédents
mandats donc on continue on a transféré
nos locaux pour pouvoir répondre à
l'évolution en fait au niveau de
l'association on avait besoin de locaux
plus fonctionnels
en fait on a déménagé nos locaux de
Versailles sur voisin Bretonneux donc on
est sur la l'agglomération de 50 ans en
Yvelines
nos prioritaires restent les mêmes enfin
là actuellement en fin d'année c'est
l'accompagnement des familles avec les
problématiques d'orientation pour les
collégiens et lycéens et puis à moyen
terme effectivement c'est l'organiser la
rentrée sur l'ensemble des régimes
scolaires qui se profile il y aura
forcément des interrogations et les
parents vont sans doute vous vous
solliciter aujourd'hui la FCPE des
Yvelines représente quoi combien
d'adhérents vous vous avez on a un peu
plus de 3500 adhérents sur l'ensemble de
des Yvelines
pour vous il faut progresser
est-ce que c'est suffisant on n'est pas
une association de consommateurs donc on
peut pas ça se mesure pas en fait en
nombre d'adhérents
est-ce qu'on constate en fait c'est que
on a beaucoup d'appels de parents
un peu désorientés par rapport à ce
moment c'est l'orientation ou
effectivement une maîtrise pas forcément
les codes la façon de remplir les
dossiers et les enfants se retrouvent
sans affectation ou avec des affectation
qui était pas du tout désirées donc
c'est vrai que notre force c'est le fait
de d'avoir en fait des salariés une
structure et les salariés et c'est un
point positif pour les parents qui
trouve finalement en appui pour être
écouté et pour être conseillé au
quotidien justement par exemple cette
famille et ses familles que vous
mentionnez qui ont des affectations pour
leurs enfants qui ne conviennent pas ils
vous pose la question qu'est-ce que je
peux faire vous intervenez comment déjà
en fait on prend l'ensemble des éléments
au dossier pour comprendre en fait
pourquoi on en est là en fait au moment
où il nous appelle et on a également des
liens on va dire privilégiés mais il y a
des instances sur lesquels on siège on
rencontrer régulièrement les
intervenants au niveau de l'éducation
et pareil au niveau des services le fait
d'avoir la compétence des parents sont
passés par là c'est ça l'intérêt aussi
la Fédération c'est qu'on mutualise nos
expériences donc quand on arrive au
niveau de l'école primaire des parents
des collèges et des lycées sont passés
par là avant et donc nous forment et
nous informe et c'est ça qui est
important voilà entre les différentes
les différents parents des différents
niveaux scolaires alors quel rôle pour
la FCPE qu'attendez-vous plus
généralement d'un représentant de
parents d'élèves c'est notre question du
jour micro-trottoir et puis vous pourrez
répondre juste après
on va dire tout ce qui est travail
scolaire extrascolaire la sécurité des
enfants dans l'école et en dehors de
l'école aussi des cours déjà le suivi
voir le suivi des enfants
sérieusement parce que je pense que
l'éducation nationale a bien changé
depuis quelques années ça sert à faire
la liaison entre les parents et puis le
corps enseignant et les enfants c'est
défendre le droit des enfants ce qu'ils
ne peuvent pas dire on va dire à l'école
est-ce qu'ils ont besoin de dire si on
veut que ça marche un petit peu si on
veut que les parents s'investissent un
petit peu dans l'éducation de leur
enfant voilà pour l'évolution de
l'éducation nationale et ça permet en
fait de faire le lien entre l'école et
les parents parce que les parents sont
malheureusement pas aussi disponibles
pour venir chercher les enfants et
permettre de voir les les instituteurs
ou les institutrices donc bah oui ça
fait ça crée le lien en fait on a
notamment entendu au cours de ce
micro-trottoir amélioré les cours c'est
le rôle de la Fédération des parents
chef des parents d'élèves d'intervenir
auprès des enseignants pour modifier les
cours alors les gens se trompent un
petit peu je pense que il manque des
peut-être des termes dans la phrase
est-ce que c'est la qualité est-ce que
c'est la quantité quantité c'est sûr ce
qu'on ce que l'on remonte régulièrement
c'est les problèmes de remplacement au
niveau de la Fédération effectivement je
vais pas dire qu'on les points
régulièrement mais on se rend compte
qu'effectivement il y a un vrai problème
aujourd'hui et que finalement un enfant
qui arrive au niveau de la terminale il
a pas du tout le nombre de d'enseignes
enseignements qui étaient prévus sur le
papier
donc sur ce domaine là vous pouvez
intervenir oui on intervient
systématiquement déjà au niveau des
collèges et des lycées au niveau des
réunions des conseils d'administration
et pareil au niveau du primaire
c'est pas une c'est pas une surprise
mais il y a eu beaucoup de problèmes de
remplacement sur certains de
circonscriptions effectivement le fait
d'avoir une vision élargie et pas
seulement sur une école ça nous permet
de prendre conscience des difficultés
sur le terrain et de discuter
directement avec les inspecteurs donc
c'est aussi un plus
éducation nationale se passe bien il
faut encore les renforcer vous arrivez à
avoir des discussions
on discute on discute alors facilement
ça dépend des sujets
mais on discute c'est des liens plutôt
ouverts en fait c'est vrai que je pense
que tout le monde gagne à se connaître
et on prend le temps de les discussions
quand il faut les prendre
j'ai pas l'impression que ce soit fermé
du tout
aujourd'hui un poids
leurs enfants ne peuvent pas faire
d'activité suffisamment enrichissantes
ce qui est pas le cas dans d'autres
communes la FCPE un rôle à jouer là
alors oui on a un rôle à jouer je corrig
juste en fait les nouveaux temps ça
concerne également les maternelles
et les commentaires oui en fait alors
déjà au niveau des en fait au niveau de
la de l'association on fonctionne avec
différents échelons au niveau local au
niveau de la ville effectivement les
conseils locaux
on fait partie des comités de pilotage
et des comités techniques qui ont été
mis en place par les communes ou parfois
aussi par les inspecteurs lorsque les
communes n'ont pas voulu jouer le jeu
et oui là c'était
il y a un rôle à jouer en fait en tant
que représentant puisque
c'est de montrer effectivement l'intérêt
et de partager le regard que chacun a en
fait sur les temps scolaires et
périscolaire qui ne va pas être le même
d'un point de vue de l'élu d'un point de
vue des enseignants et d'un point de vue
des parents et y compris les d'un point
de vue des animateurs qui participent
sur ces temps donc oui ça a été ça joue
un poids et effectivement ça aussi ça
permet aussi d'avoir un certain
arbitrage et de faire entendre la voix
des parents au niveau les cheveux en
fait au dessus au niveau départemental
aussi puisque il y a les temps on
rencontre aussi des élus et c'est aussi
une façon de dialoguer et prendre du
recul et de faire avancer les choses
au-delà de ces rythmes scolaires qui
concentre une bonne partie de
l'actualité autour de l'éducation il y a
aussi la BCD de l'égalité cette saison
saignements qui devait être dispensés
qui seront finalement supprimés il y
aura une mallette pédagogique enfin tout
n'a pas été encore très très clair
là-dessus qu'elle regarde vous avez
alors sincèrement là au niveau de la du
78 enfin des Yvelines c'est vrai qu'on
est passé par une année très difficile
par rapport à cette problématique des
problématiques non c'est pas un problème
la BCD de l'égalité à n'a pas été
expérimenté sur le territoire et
pourtant il y a eu des inquiétudes avec
cette théorie du genre qui revenait des
garçons
pour contester alors qu'il n'y avait pas
encore de tests ne serait-ce que dans le
département effectivement ça rejoignait
la problématique du mariage homosexuel
enfin tout c'est beaucoup mélangé autour
de ça alors qu'à l'origine c'est
vraiment en fait de restaurer l'égalité
fille garçon aujourd'hui
je pense que c'est un petit peu marche
arrière la fin c'est marche arrière un
petit peu comme les rites en fait où on
a senti qu'effectivement avec cette
assouplissement pour nous ça pouvait
paraître être une marche arrière comme
si effectivement l'idée qui était lancée
et
vous aurez préféré que ce soit affirmé
que ce soit plus clair et qu'on avance
c'était plus simple en fait tel que
c'était posé dès le départ une dernière
question votre chantier principal pour
ce mandat pour cette année de mandat
continuer à former les parents informer
et désinformer effectivement par rapport
à toutes les informations
contradictoires que peuvent enfin
recevoir les parents
merci Valérie Traumat nouvelle
présidente des Yvelines présentes ce
soir dans le 7 8 l'actu après
l'éducation la petite enfance et les
places en crèche qui restent difficiles
à trouver pour les parents les
entreprises maintenant se saisissent du
problème elles ont décidé de créer leur
propre structures et cela profite
d'ailleurs à tout le monde claire
Cambier et Juliette pousse en
pourcentage
une nouvelle crèche a ouvert ses portes
à Bois-d'Arcy le 5 mai dernier ce matin
ont fêté l'inauguration officielle pour
la ville il s'agit d'un appel d'air 40
places supplémentaires pour un coup
minime la construction a été prise en
charge par l'entreprise de crèche la
maison bleue et le coup de
fonctionnement est réduit car dans cette
crèche privée la moitié des places est
réservée à la municipalité l'autre aux
entreprises pour le fonctionnement comme
une bonne partie des places sont
commercialisées auprès d'entreprises qui
payent les places pour leurs salariés en
fait la ville ne paye qu'une partie du
fonctionnement les familles bénéficient
de tarifs CAF
identiques à ceux d'une crèche
municipale pour le moment la crèche Les
Minipouss occupe de 22 enfants mais elle
devrait afficher complet dès la rentrée
prochaine car les place manquent dans le
département dans le département on a
donc 14 800 places réparties sur 378
établissements donc c'est un beau
chiffre mais c'est quand même je pense
insuffisant
la particularité des crèches de la
maison bleue et de s'appuyer sur une
pédagogie dit du respect on y favorise
l'autonomie en s'adaptant au rythme de
l'enfant et on attache une attention
particulière européen l'enfant a une
référence qui s'occupe de lui qui lui
prodigue tous les soins dont il a besoin
et c'est toujours la même en fait voilà
et donc en fait on met en place ce
système de référence avec toute
l'importance des repères en fait avec
des choses qui l'enfant mange toujours à
la même place toujours avec la même
personne
dort toujours au même endroit voilà il y
a des choses comme ça qui se répètent
tous les jours et qui créent en fait une
sécurité affective chez l'enfant dans
les Yvelines on compte aujourd'hui une
vingtaine de crèches de la maison bleue
la maison d'édition rue du Mont de
relance l'opération était des bouquins
solidaires depuis 10 ans entre la
mijoint et l'ami août dès que deux
livres de l'opération sont vendus un
ouvrage est offert à un enfant dit
oublier des vacances ouvrages offert
lors d'une journée d'évasion la mer
organisée par le Secours populaire et
vous voyez défiler les couvertures des
livres sélectionnés cette année deux HT
le troisième offert pour ses enfants
défavorisés c'est très simple en une
décennie d'existence 100000 enfants ont
ainsi déjà reçu un livre grâce à cet été
des bouquins solidaires menés par Rue du
Monde maison d'édition basée à
Voisins-le-Bretonneux la RD10 entre
Saint-Cyr-l'École et Versailles ce sont
25000 véhicules quotidiennement et ce
dimanche le temps d'une après-midi pas
une seule voiture sur le bitume mais des
rollers des vélos et des piétons une
expérience peu commune proposée par la
Communauté d'Agglomération de Versailles
Grand Parc baptisé La Grande
déambulation Catherine zolato pour les
commentaires Elodie moine pour les
images
une heure de 10 vide de voiture l'image
est rare et pour cause la route qui
relie ainsi à l'école à Versailles et
souvent très fréquenté mais le temps
d'une journée ce dimanche les vélos et
les piétons ont eu le droit de déambuler
ce sont des moments privilégiés
sympathiques ça va être fermé un
dimanche par mois un peu comme ce qui se
fait à Paris en fait les molécules quoi
c'est vrai qu'avoir les voix sur berges
de fermer ça permet de bien profiter de
enfin des vues de Paris et puis bah là
ça serait bien que ce soit pareil quoi
c'était formidable j'ai déjà vu jamais
vu la RD10 vite comme ça et réservé aux
piétons donc on a bien profité on habite
en plus dans la dans Versailles et on a
les voitures qui nous défilent tout le
temps dans la rue et là il y a personne
non ça a été parfait ça fait du bien
quand même de pas avoir de voiture ici
et pouvoir faire du vélo
et même sur une route sans voiture on
n'oublie pas la sécurité ici les
questions de prévention mais de
prévention à vélo un atelier était
réservé aux plus jeunes pour apprendre à
bien manier lors de roues une
cinquantaine d'enfants a participé sont
responsables après si aussi le moment
oui ça fait du bien bien sûr de voir un
dimanche après-midi sans voiture c'est
agréable bien sûr
agréable certes mais fermer une route à
forte circulation cela demande une
certaine organisation pour la communauté
d'agglomération de Versailles
grands-park l'idée à germé il y a deux
ans il a fallu un an pour concrétiser
l'opération une fois par an c'est
possible plus souvent comme à Paris
compliqué bloquez Versailles c'est une
ville très compliquée en circulation
donc je pense que c'est pas très jouable
toutes les semaines mais une fois par an
c'est un beau défi qu'on peut relever
oui une première opération qui sera donc
reconduite environ 5000 personnes ont
arpenté dimanche le bitume Versailles
merci de nous avoir suivi sur tvfils 78
le journal revient demain mercredi au
même heure et je vous retrouve aussi ce
mardi soir pour la dernière édition du 7
8 politique de la saison avec Valérie
Pécresse Christine Boutin mais aussi
l'un des responsables locaux du parti
radical qui vient de désigner Laurent et
Nara sa tête face à ramaya d'excellentes
soirée